so what you got coming up Bobby don't do
that man
so what you got on your plate no don't
do that man I just um
I think one of my dreams is and I and
maybe one day we can make this happen
but with you me Theo Tom Segura you're
Bryan Callen a lot of us pot we all can
act Yeah right
yeah I think we should all band together
and create some sort of movie oh yeah I
think that we could get the funding we
write a really funny script that goes
off when somebody gets too boring sorry
I turned it off so go ahead because it's
on notifications yeah is that we're at
what no I turn it off so we're not nine
up but is that where we're at right now
what die talk I you know I express you
know getting mad you getting upset with
me but you have to remember the app was
on should I be honest with you that's
not an app that's just a sound thing
that you have and you pressed it do you
think I looked it up on YouTube alarm
sound no okay look at your phone now
no why cuz I have a code on it and your
deference this time and I'm not gonna
let you do that why and I'm not gonna do
i yeah yeah yeah so what I'm saying is
that why can't we do that
we can do that and I do would you do it
yeah what way specifically what would
you do listen to what our [ __ ] said I
didn't know is I think that we have I
think that I think that you me Callen
yes Brandon yeah
Theo a bunch of us right Tom Segura Bert
we all have you know our little arm yes
and write that it's great it's great
we should write a scrip oh I see what
you're and do like a comedy I see what
you're saying right I'll move the only
fun yes Ella I think that it would do
well I do - I've had that Jia Jia's in
there everyone I know had the same
thought but the thing is this
is on the table because if I sit on it
I'll be uneven and it's and I'll get
scoliosis if because of this if this
wasn't thick enough I'd put it under
there no problem and I wouldn't get
scoliosis right right so if I write a
script with you guys then we all split
the money right and then this ends up
going in my back pocket right and I
don't get scoliosis or I can leave it on
here but can I say this okay all right
you've already been to the top right
yeah come down and bring some of your
friends up there no you did I've seen
your dick it's long okay it's juicy it's
perfection woman maybe kiss the tip all
right but I'm not I don't really have
any thing is that I see I know that you
have homes okay
and I said that plural plural okay did I
not you did you have little doggies all
right do I always say this right now all
right and it may be not true it is all
right you would send me photos like look
at how much look at my dogs aren't they
cute now and they're like running around
yeah where are they running on top of
money you've sent me those my dogs were
cute he was mainly about the dog I know
but you know that me your dogs on a pile
of money all right you've done that all
right I went to jokeboys house Yeah
right
oh and from behind me he had his friend
pour money on my head and he got you
know what he said well that's just merch
and there was thousands of dollars Wow
I want to see the mountain top as well
Friday all right and so what I'm saying
to you is is that can you help can we
all help each other yeah because I you
know what I'll be honest with you I'm
gonna sit down yeah I'll be honest with
you I love doing stand-up yeah I love
doing this podcast but I also love don't
you love acting yeah I like it's fun
it's fun when you're like you know free
but especially with
with friends hello my friend yeah you
know and during your coverage yeah I
could be laughing too like you laughs I
love it
I could put out something that's fun
right I'm in and I'll fund it
crowdfunding yeah we're a crowdfunded
and also the thing is is that I'm not
talking about I know because you were in
xxx what's up Netflix right so you all
with me undateable you're a great actor
and can I say something right now even
before you did any acting I did a table
reading with you and that's good acting
what about this where the [ __ ] do you
get off oh I think it's really quite
nice oh we can do that a British love
song you can be in a to give no lines no
way oh no okay absolutely no lines yay
but I think that if you're listening to
right now my little papayas I think that
we can create something outside of this
Hollywood system because we're in it you
know but it's like you know I show up to
splitting up together and they give me
lines I love the show that's not your
right but it's like there are times
where I want to be with my friend right
and have yeah I mean a goose time a
goose time you know so I think we can do
that and I'm gonna call I'm gonna call
the Rat King I'm gonna call segura I'm
gonna make that happen
okay now you're hot all right let's do
it I've been did you put the air on
you did I figure out now but it's too
late it's one of those things where it's
just too late yeah I want to say this is
that um I just I just like your
situation right now
thanks man do you feel good I feel great
yeah I love my life and I and I think
you're in a great situation to all you
guys now know mainly about the kind of
closet but I think it's really great man
no because I I remember when you were
starting and to see you now and you know
I feel the same way about Sebastian as
well
you know and I do it my sound like I'm
kissing ass no no be honest I'm
reminiscing no you're [ __ ] reminisce
we're all mighty mighty might be a
player right now no
you're not a player dude yeah am I being
goose silly no it's silly goose but yeah
yeah it might be serious serious goose
you're being a serious yeah I just I
just think that we should you know
everyone supposed to stop and just you
know acknowledge what yeah I do too you
know I [ __ ] I Love You Man I think
you do great and you're right you know
what you're always gonna be what you're
always gonna be okay and you're gonna
flow you'll always be what you'll always
have Facebook guys so look at Twilight
vampire yeah yeah and you have a very
good penis you have some character
defects that you need to work on my lips
are very juicy you have character
defects you have to work on okay you
know I mean this isn't dr. Phil yeah and
what are we doing we are at 55 Wow let's
do eyes now
[Music]